le marché
[Applaudissements]
chloé olivères es sétif and gentilleau
sur scène est clair frétel à la mise en
scène raconte la vie d'une mère lors du
festival d'avignon 2016 elle remporte le
coup de coeur du club de la presse
on était hyper contente parce que on s'y
attendait pas du tout au fond plus
c'était un jury majoritairement masculin
donc on était d'autant plus ravis que ea
nous sélectionne les fumeuses
occasionnels c'est fini de la découverte
de la grossesse aux premiers instants
avec bébé en passant par l'annoncent à
l'employeur toutes les étapes sont
décryptés avec humour et surtout de la
franchise pour casser l'image sacralisé
de la maternité
c'est pas une pièce comique parce que
c'est pas ça qu'on cherchait mais on a
voulu aborder des sujets qui n'étaient
pas forcément simple qui parfois été cru
mais c'est vrai que comme on part de
notre vécu et que on a aussi pas envie
de se prendre trop au sérieux
forcément l'autodérision il n'y arrivait
très vite on a surtout travaillé sur le
fait d'être très proche de soi donc en
fait sur une forme de sincérité
ce sont deux comédiennes qui sont deux
femmes et qui sont deux mamans donc en
fait c'est pas un thème de travail de
personnages extérieurs finalement c'est
un travail de chercher d'amener au
plateau quelque chose de d'être vraiment
à vif et au présent au plateau joué plus
de 20 fois cet été la pièce est née d'un
besoin de s'exprimer et s'inspire de
simone de beauvoir et elisabeth badinter
interprété pour la première fois en
février 2015 le spectacle était soutenue
et coproduit par le prisme à elancourt
elles correspondent à beaucoup de
paramètres et de critères ce qui est en
jeu c'est de soutenir la création
émergente donc de jeunes artistes qui
ont envie de dire quelque chose
la façon de le dire c'est
essentiellement le jeu dramatique
l'écriture et pas forcément des douanes
de décors ou des tonnes d'effets
spéciaux
on est vraiment au coeur du jeu
théâtral et de l'écriture il faut
prendre garde que les décisions et
sentiments avoué de la jeune mère ne
correspond pas toujours à ses désirs
profonds la pièce continue sur sa lancée
elle se joue au théâtre du rond point
jusqu'au 2 octobre